[Music]
eSports fans are living in an era of
heroes
this the earliest Trailblazers in these
games didn't have many role models and
playing video games professionally was a
far-fetched dream
they were the pioneer so to speak right
and they had no one
they were laughs at that weird had
shittiest salaries no salaries and
pretty bad marketing of branding and we
can look up these people but a new
generation of players who grew up in a
world where full-time eSports was
already within reach are among us since
I was 12 13 like my plan was to be an
eSports athlete and as new games enter
the eSports arena
some of those players have become their
biggest stars seizing the opportunity to
get in on the ground floor and build a
competitive legacy Mick listened caught
the eSports fever and knew he had to
work harder than everyone else if he
wanted to live that dream in his teens
he tried to break into the hottest games
at the time Pearson from now the current
et same company controls back then no I
have been following in each scene ever
since it came around and I wanted what
they had and then when Rainbow six siege
came out he grabbed hold of his destiny
I actually just reached my 10,000 hour
you know total across those almost three
years and that is the current record for
any pro player and possibly also
potentially out there this is his story
Niklas Penghu Morrison was born in
Denmark in 1997 and was interested in
video games at a young age he loved
Warcraft 3 and even learned English from
playing World of Warcraft when he was 7
before moving on to counter-strike and
eventually League of Legends video games
to spend my childhood like that's been
my saving grace you know kidney with the
right friends the right area so from the
age of 4 I got my own computer but
through it all he developed a
fascination with an idea that seemed
far-fetched at the time becoming a
professional eSports athlete once he
decided to pursue eSports greatness he
wasted no time at choosing a quirky
handle at one point I was the OREA we
got a GoPro pick a name stick with it
and be proud of it right
what are you proud of favorite color
spirit animal blue penguin filthy ello
you crispy lue was taken because it's
too common without a father in the
picture
Tango's mother result to support her son
in whatever he chose to do his attempts
to play league of legends and heroes of
the storm professionally didn't work out
though he did play in some qualifiers
for major events but it wasn't long
before one of his friends introduced him
to a brand new title Rainbow six siege
my best friend showed me the EP trailer
and it was a tactical shooter game
whereas counter-strike didn't really
appeal to me much because it's a lot
like TDM style a lot to new style you
know Frank advised the e3 trailer you
come down and rebel from a helicopter
you repelling the walls you can hop
reach windows you got all these hostages
and tactical angles
approach was really appealing to me and
siege provided Penghu with an
opportunity that those other games
couldn't the ability to get in at the
beginning I really meant rendom forum
post stating my name my age my
dedication its I think the title
specifically looking to go pro or at
least the top one guy responded called
icon and from check we made a team with
me him for like three German players we
went pro so December 1st 2015 the game
came out December 25th I joined the team
called r3x
that then became tennis boards in
January 16 his mother supported him as
he tried to turn pro and gave him six
months to do so as long as he continued
to pay rent and after he joined Penta
sports in February 2016 he had to
shorten his handle and decided on
penguin my name is suppose to be Penta -
blue penguin which is 20 characters how
to shorten it made it pin to pink pool
rather than pinch of blue after winning
the pro league year one season ones
group stage with Penta he returned home
to a realization he didn't want to do
anything else I got home Sunday Monday
morning we had breakfast together and
the most depressing looking person ever
eating my toast and she's like what's
wrong I'm like I just had this amazing
experience you know feeling my career
out now I'm about to wake up at 7:30
a.m. for something I don't want to do
before a course I don't feel like I said
purpose before I study that don't be
like missing school meant that Penghu
was eventually kicked out because of his
poor attendance record but he quickly
showed that the tough decision was
worthwhile Penta won the pro league year
one season one finals and Penghu took
home $5,000 the most money he had ever
made not only did that prize money prove
that he had what it took to make it as a
pro but it also led to more independence
and a greater opportunity to pursue the
dream as he started to stream Penghu
became known another way in the Rainbow
six community as an entertainer
what do you do I'm killing everybody I'm
just looking for a dude I'm rounding
dudes I brought it everywhere in terms
of his competitive career though there
was just one problem I was worthy worst
pro league player in FPS game ever
because I came from League of Legends
either experience so I invented my own a
style that relied around anything bought
if PS teams I would hold an angle
play-off reaction time I'm young and it
worked
whereas most people would they would
play off aiming and accuracy as the game
went on those who character called black
kids that came out in year 1 season 2
would had a face shield which means you
couldn't kill him but headshots and I
was like oh I'm a terrible player I'm
gonna pick up this extremely overpowered
character and I'm gonna use as a
handicap until I learn how to play the
game properly so in professional play I
was thinking like if only to mask the
fact that I was terrible the game and in
my spare time I was grinding 10 12 hours
a day with anything but light beer to
like catch up on the mechanics that I
was bad at while he initially focused on
supporting his team Penghu Zayn steadily
improved and it helped them amass
competitive success giving Penta almost
Penghu they're getting the revenge oh
here we go
second Bangu beside it now it's gonna
try to rush on over here snow for the
kill it doesn't work out in Penghu now
knows exactly where he then is gonna get
the first kill you go for the deagle
kill gonna get it
Penghu dropping the clutch right there's
beside they will fall here we go
speaking of penguin are you doing
almost getting the kill there just go
down by late 2017 the Penta sports
roster had amassed some major
competitive victories the roster had a
four player core of Goga fabian Eunice
and Penghu and added shatta in December
2017 it was a group of players from a
number of European countries all of whom
were speaking English but while many
considered them one of the world's best
rosters they would finally have a chance
to prove it at the game's biggest
competition yet the six Invitational
2018 offered a $500,000 prize pool but
more than that it was a chance for
redemption Penta had failed to qualify
for the event in 2017 falling second to
EUR onyx gaming in the EU qualifier
pingu's inside now has the defuse of a
secretly shot guns him down sigh vs.
renewals it is a 1v1 smoke inside for
the shotgun it doesn't yeah but he
doesn't matter there's no time and with
that your onyx are going to Montreal in
a month's time now Penghu have the
opportunity to prove that this new
roster was the best team in the world as
he continued to grow in both popularity
and skill it was obvious that Penghu was
becoming one of the game's biggest stars
but with that spotlight came other
challenges I get I call that one guy's
close dude that's meant for me because I
can kill that guy right back down you
betta cookie
you betta dude you [ __ ] betta know
cuz you can win the argument that's why
I don't have fight it out of course
there's a backup because it's because
you're wrong it's hard to a cue when
you're wrong opinionated and confident
Penghu became known for controversial
opinions and the occasional angry
outburst coming from being a cocky 18
year old dropout with no social
experience due to him playing too many
video games and then you get a voice you
know a fans a group of people that
listens to you when they shouldn't as
well it was hard to learn because I grew
so fast we're the first and growing team
in the world and at the time in year two
and it went way too fast a country often
the most popular streamer in the Rainbow
six category he was a first point of
contact for prospective players he and
all mention of Penta were removed from
an ubisoft article previewing the six
invitational 2018 Ubisoft even
approached him and told him that they
might have to take disciplinary action
for next season
it was my darkest place in my career
because I was in such a bad spot with
Ubisoft with all the food fans with pro
players with Twitter with drama with
sponsors and organizations my girlfriend
broke up with me or we splitted like at
the tournament everything fell apart and
I had this relative check where yourself
came in and said we might disqualify you
next year we might just efforts avenged
autonomy and I was like that that's my
career that's what I worked for it's
what I've you know had that I wanted I
got it and I'm about to lose it I look
behind me my teammates and they look at
me like my enemies would look at me
right because if I could just wanna
fight they could disqualify I'm ruining
their careers
at the Invitational Penta went to and
Owen groups defeating both team vitality
and na favorites evil geniuses that
second result alone seemed to reinforce
the opinion that Penta were the odds on
favorites and as they made a dominant
run through the bracket there was little
reason to doubt them the very first game
on stage was against ends we're not
taking the victory to 0 and then the
semi-final was against black dragons and
now was our redemption fight right there
ended up taking the victory as well at
that point you know we're really really
happy and in the grand finals
it was the matchup that many had wanted
the best of Europe against Enys
brightest stars evil geniuses we figure
out later that day that we actually play
each in the final so we're kind of with
a red line were kind of back to where we
started you know we're up against eg
which is like a group stage we've played
each other before meaning that we knew
how each other played and there's a bit
of fire across from Penghu was troy
canadian Jairus louse key who had won
the invitational that Penghu had been
forced to sit out
I love eg I fell in love with CTMS their
call before I love Troy he was like my
idol
he won i GL he was featuring the
documentary I was like I want to be
there I wanna be that guy and then we
faced him an invitational and I was like
if we beat them that's gonna like shift
I can become that person by beating them
but at the same time I get to fight the
best team in the world at the time the
two tightness we one day reporting
season Pacific Raziel they won the piece
invitationals they had the most success
they had the previous title and we in a
best-of-five final for the first time
ever biggest stage and that was facing
troy that was the only thing I wanted
that had kind of been like a matchup
that really there was a lot of build-up
to it because we had won two titles
previously when we were under continuum
in year 1 season 3 and then the previous
Invitational and then Penta had been the
only other team to win multiple titles
and that's still the case we're still be
the only two teams that have won
multiple titles but the best-of-five
matchup was far different from groups
evil geniuses took the first map easily
down by BC who goes for the double and
gets it Judah's eliminated it evil
geniuses take their first round of the
series the next map was more of a
struggle but eg would once again emerge
victorious putting Penta in an early o
to hole
be honest I've said this and joke about
this like I think I was happier when we
went up to oh that when I won the first
imitation I was just like screaming one
more map one more map Fabien said there
is screaming like what the [ __ ] could we
do we're so terrible we can do better do
you guys wanna [ __ ] lose I don't want
to [ __ ] lose gonna bother and win now
right it kind of brought out everybody's
frustrations we kind of yelled at each
other we got everything I thought you
did this you did that I thought you know
[ __ ] that I hate you whichever and then
he said the whole first night I don't
want you lose to you and I think it is
click like no we don't want to restart
we get to win and we went out you know
when an animal is trapped up against the
wall that's when is it scary justified
you cannot flee anymore it was on the
third map cafe where the tide turned
they pulled out like this Montaigne
strategy that we had never seen before
and basically like completely destroyed
us because we'd had no idea how to react
to it
Canadian once again in a situation where
he will need to clutch it so one before
take him down to next Noelle he'll take
Koga but he now has a shield in his way
very difficult when only one build
eliminate amante but Penta takes their
first map then tend to even the series
with a win on bank two versus for Yunus
from deep inside of the server stairs
will get BCE on response on to Pangu
there's only one defender left to deny
this and it's not gonna happen
and so in fake put it onto the final map
of this best-of-five and at the end on
coastline Penghu found himself on the
wrong side of a 2v1
and made history left two of the best
know employers on
the captain sufficient Fragger bobbing
down its Penghu the ass just waiting or
rather the apana just waiting they'll
look to push together diffuser in a
position where they'll have to see when
the hip on it goes through when we'll
cover the doorway as they start to the
future and you go through one on the
young getting on the second they're
often known as the best team in the
world that we're having that distinction
until today
Penza hard or world champion the second
invitation
[Applause]
the six Invitational 2018 was a
formative moment for Penghu highs and
lows combined to make a potent turning
point in his approach to being a pro
player the proposed ban never came
Penghu has internalized the impact his
actions can have not just on this
generation of fans but everyone that
doesn't mean that he's lost the opinions
he was known for more than he tries to
be as constructive as possible in
communicating them during year three the
team won the European Pro League finals
and came second to the surging Brazilian
team liquid at the Global Finals as they
continue the strong play they had become
known for pingu's team was acquired by
two to eSports
I wanted you to I wanted something to be
proud of ten percent and to say that now
we have visually made it not insisting
on price well money-wise trophies we
have a name a brand we are international
we're on a bigger scene now and Penghu
has begun to immortalize his career in a
tattoo his achievements literally
inscribed on his body so it started with
the smoke character so this is smoke
from ink from the game the SAS squad ICS
enemies down here with the Hound head
here it's a uniform in the game that was
only a plan per usable by 40 players who
skipped it to us it's like a beta
testing as a smoke coming out and keep
the smoke canisters and sketch it
obviously had a 16-6 logo representing
the victory their memories and hardships
and we got my own personal friend who's
the tinkerer brand somebody to emerge
for my wallpaper etc for merchandising
first one
and then we have kind of everything
together it's a goofy cartoony penguin
with this seed such hammer that's the
trophy of invitationals we have three
skulls each representing each party
victory so here one sees one uses one in
you to season two and then we're gonna I
would like to integrate Pence and g2 is
like a start and nightwear right now
remember that and obviously we gotta add
the Paris feature so we're gonna keep
building up to about the bicep and then
you know wasn't style working now we can
maybe keep going up okay with another
win over eg at the Paris major this time
a very definitive 3o Penghu has once
again climbed to the very top of siege
competition but this time unlike the
last he more fully understands the
stakes he isn't one of the eSports
pioneers others walk that path first but
someday to some aspiring esports pro he
might become their role model thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button